the top United Nations official in Mali
told the security Council on Monday that
the U.N peacekeeping Force known as
minutema is on schedule to depart the
country by the end of the year
but elgasan Wayne also acknowledged that
the situation is volatile and dangerous
difficulties have emerged in the
implementation of the first phase of the
withdrawal plan the last Convoy of blue
helmets equipment and materials which
withdrew from the Bear peacekeeping Camp
to go towards the city of Timbuktu took
51 hours to cover a distance of 57
kilometers and the Convoy was attacked
twice by an unidentified extremist
element four blue helmets were injured
and three vehicles were damaged before
the convoys arrival into Timbuktu
despite the challenges Mali reaffirmed
it does not plan to alter the withdrawal
date
I would like to say that the government
of Mali does not foresee an extension of
the deadline for U.N peacekeepers
departure beyond the 31st of December
this year
there are also other uncertainties
mali's transitional government had
welcomed the help of fighters from
Russia's Wagner group but with the death
of Wagner's founder your gabni pergozin
the group's future in Mali is now in
doubt something Western countries
welcomed the Russian mercenary group
Wagner is directly linked to Human
Rights atrocities in Mali including the
systematic use of conflict-related
sexual violence
as illustrated by recent events in
Russia they are part of the problem not
the solution in Mali and Beyond barring
any unforeseen circumstances this likely
will be the last time Security Council
Members are briefed before the
withdrawal deadline and given the
precarious security situation there is
certainly an air of trepidation about
what could be to come but at this point
when it comes to U.N peacekeepers
permanently leaving Mali it appears
there is no turning back
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera at the United
Nations